bonsoir à tous ravis de vous retrouver
sur figaro live sur lefigaro.fr et sur
la chaîne youtube du figaro ce soir nous
allons analyser décrypter le débat qui
vient d'opposer eric zemmour et valérie
pécresse ça s'est terminé il ya quelques
instants sur tf1 et sur lci un débat
très attendu au cours duquel les deux
candidats en berne dans les sondages eh
bien on jouer gros ils ont cherché à se
démarquer pour en parler je suis avec
benjamin morel politologue bonjour dans
la main bonsoir merci d'être avec nous
vous êtes politologue et maître de
conférences à l'université paris 2 c'est
ça alors avant toute chose n'hésitez pas
à nous envoyer tous vos tous vos
commentaires toute autre réaction à nous
dire tout simplement ce que vous avez
pensé de ce débat si vous l'avez vu en
tous les cas vous pouvez nous poser vos
questions je les relayeurs et en direct
et nous tenterons bien entendu d'y
répondre alors benjamin morel première
question un petit peu général qu'est ce
que vous avez pensé de ce débat de
manière générale qu'est ce qu'il faut en
retenir alors comme vous le disais on
avait un débat en jeu c'est à dire que
pour les deux candidats il fallait
arriver à reconstruire a retrouvé une
forme de dynamique dans un moment qui
est assez difficile pour l'un comme pour
l'autre et donc à partir de là il
fallait jouer sur une incarnation et on
a vu dans ce débat que on a eu deux
candidats qui ont tenté en effet de
vraiment mettre au centre de leur
posture et bien cette question de
l'incarnation on a une valérie pécresse
qui a joué sur jouer la compétence face
à un eric zemmour est bien qu'elle a
tenté de dont elle a tenté de démontrer
que il ne pourrait pas faire parce qu'en
réalité ils ne maîtrisaient pas le fond
des dossiers de l'autre côté eric
zemmour à sur jouer la position de la
cohérence en essayant de démontrer d'un
côté que valérie pécresse et bien avait
pu manquer de cohérence avec les
positions qui avaient été les siennes et
que son programme est bien ne mènerait
pas quelque chose de très différent que
ce qu'a fait la droite jadis où ce que
ferait emmanuel macron demain donc on
voit que en construisant l'autre
candidat comme étant le négatif de soi
même on a réellement deux candidats qui
ont tenté de montrer que et bien il
incarnait quelque chose dans cette
campagne cohérence contre crédibilité
alors on va parler du fond effectivement
benjamin morel mais il y a une première
chose qu'on peut qu'on peut dire sur ce
débat c'est que les échanges ont été
extrêmement vif les journalistes gilles
bouleau et ruth elkrief sont intervenus
à plusieurs reprises pour demander et
bien aux candidats de d'arrêter de
s'apostropher de la sorte
est-ce que ça n'a pas un petit peu
tourné à la cacophonie à un moment donné
il ya eu quelques moments on est en
effet assez cacophonique c'est le moins
qu'on puisse dire et je suis pas sûr
d'ailleurs que ça ait servi tout à fait
la stratégie des candidats c'est à dire
que d'un côté comme de l'autre il y
avait la volonté je pense comme je
l'expliquais tout à l'heure de montrer
que à travers ce qu'il dévoilait chez
l'autre c'est à dire d'un côté le manque
de cohérence de l'autre le manque de
précision eh bien il pouvait camper
quelque chose mais du coup les
interruptions multiples et bien tendent
à des présidentialiser un candidat or
l'enjeu pour l'un comme pour l'autre
aujourd'hui c'est un enjeu de premier
tour évidemment mais également un enjeu
de second tour et cet enjeu de second
tour quand vous regardez aujourd'hui les
enquêtes qui les montrent relativement
faible face à emmanuel macron plus
faible par exemple que marine le pen ne
serait fait face à emmanuel macron au
second tour l'enjeu de
présidentialisation de crédibilisation à
travers justement la capacité à incarner
cette posture est extrêmement importante
et là du coup à en ayant peut-être une
approche trop premier tour on a deux
candidats qui ont montré quelques signes
de faiblesse justement dans une posture
pour l'une peut-être trop agressive et
pour l'autre et bien qu'ils avaient du
mal en réalité à dérouler son programme
sans interrompre sa concurrente pour le
coup c'est plutôt l'un des ratés deux
des candidats lors de ce débat sur les
réseaux sociaux vous parlez de rater les
internautes sont quand même assez
unanimes pour justement dire que que
c'était un petit peu trop un petit peu
trop violent certains disent même que ce
soir eric zemmour comme valérie pécresse
se sont disqualifiés est-ce que vous
iriez jusque là non je n'irai pas jusque
là c'est à dire qu'encore une fois il y
avait la volonté des deux concurrents de
montrer qu'ils incarnaient quelque chose
en fait tout simplement de différent de
1 emmanuel macron et de l'autre marine
le pen est donc pour le coup il y a
malgré tout dans ce face à face et bien
une capacité à montrer qu'ils
incarnaient quelque chose mais au bout
du compte en fin de compte en effet on a
un débat qui n'a peut être pas profité à
l'un ou à l'autre comme il l'aurait
espéré c'est tout le paradoxe c'est à
dire que ce débat était un peu
vous pouvez pas être un jeu à somme
nulle c'est à dire que confronter deux
candidats qui sont en troisième position
ça fait que soit la l'emportent
franchement et donc à partir de là peut
espérer lancer une dynamique qui lui
permettent éventuellement de prendre la
deuxième ou la première place soit les
deux se neutralisent et si les deux se
neutralisent et bien c'est un peu ce
statu quo du point de vue de cette
position de cette troisième position on
a quand même à ce stade là plutôt
l'impression comme on a assisté à ça ce
soir j'aurais du mal c'est peut-être
votre prochaine question donc je suis
désolé si je si je veux ses jambes rail
appelle trop vite j'aurais du mal à
décerner la palme du vainqueur à l'un
des deux ce soir dans tous les cas vous
expliquez bien la raison pour laquelle
ils ont tous les deux fait le choix
d'être plutôt offensif ce soir mais est
ce que finalement en voulant jouer la
carte justement est bien d'être le
candidat ou la candidate offensif est ce
que finalement le grand vainqueur ce
soir ce n'est pas emmanuel macron ou
encore marine le pen qui qui joue qui
qui peut-être ont une position de
surplomb ce soir c'est peut-être en
effet emmanuel macron marine le pen si
vous voulez quand vous prenez par
exemple prenez le dernière la dernière
enquête ipsos pour le monde savait les
grandes enquêtes que fait ipsos sur
16000 sondés à peu près et donc ça
permet à ipsos d'aller assez loin dans
les détails notamment de voir les
seconds choix des électeurs et voyez que
le vrai la vraie porosité entre
de l'électorat de valérie pécresse il
est plutôt vis-à-vis elle est plutôt
vis-à-vis des manuels macron vous avez
40 % des électeurs à peu près de valérie
pécresse qui serait prêt en second choix
à aller voter emmanuel macron et 40% des
électeurs d'emmanuel macron qui seraient
prêts à voter valérie pécresse on a à
peu près les mêmes chiffres un peu moins
entre eric zemmour et marine le pen donc
on voit que on a deux candidats qui
tentent de jouer sur la même partition
mais qui partagent malgré tout est bien
une frange électoral relativement faible
à ce stade là de la campagne en tout cas
et que leurs vrais adversaires parce
qu'ils sont devant eux dans les enquêtes
d'opinion et parce qu'ils partagent avec
eux plus d'électeurs qu'il n'en
partagent entre eux et bien c'est plutôt
marine le pen et emmanuel macron le fait
qu'on ait deux candidatures qui se
neutralisent le fait qu'on est on
l'évoqué débat assez violent qui du coup
n'est pas la présidentialisation a
priori ça n'aide pas à aller chercher
ces électeurs qui sont aujourd'hui chez
emmanuel macron aujourd'hui chez marine
le pen et dont l'enjeu était pour l'un
comme pour l'autre de les ramener est ce
que c'est un pari raté alors pour les
deux candidats ce soir il va falloir
voir c'est à dire qu'il ya le débat il
ya la manière dont le débat est
interprétée il ya deux manières dans le
débat ensuite marquent l'opinion on va
voir dans les prochaines heures dans les
prochains jours eh bien les petites
phrases les moments qui ont pu être
marquante dans ce débat et la manière
dont ce débat en fait va rentrer dans la
société les gens qui regardent les
débats en règle générale noms retiennent
que quelques parties les partis qui
préfèrent les partis qui les marques les
plus on retienne parfois quelques
phrases et donc là on peut avoir au fur
et à mesure et bien quelque chose qui
portent ces deux candidats mais a priori
on a du mal à voir si on n'a pas de 2-2
de diffusion comme ça on est mal on a du
mal à voir comment est ce que ça
pourrait permettre à ce stade là de
changer lors de la campagne alors il ya
beaucoup de commentaires sur sur le chat
du figaro.fr et sur youtube n'hésitez
pas à continuer de nous envoyer vos
réactions vos réactions pardon mais
également vos questions je les pose ray
et bien à benjamin morel en direct on a
par exemple dudule 14 qui nous dit
bonsoir le duel des nullards il est
assez assez dur est-ce que voilà est-ce
que vous pensez effectivement que ce
genre de de commentaires et justifiée au
vu de la prestation des deux candidats
ce soir je le trouve un peu dur c'est à
dire je pense que 2014 et peut-être un
peu dur peut-être partisans pas mais en
tout cas on n'a pas eu de grandes
prestations je crois qu'il faut pas non
plus se mentir on n'a pas non plus des
naufrages en direct c'est à dire que on
n'a pas l'entre-deux tours des
présidentielles de 2007 où l'entre-deux
tours des présidentielles de 2017 ou là
pour le coup on avait un candidat qui
avait montré que et bien il tenait le
débat est un autre candidat qui était
beaucoup plus en difficulté qui montrait
que clairement il était dans une
situation d'infériorité mais du coup par
contraste est peut-être est-ce qu'il
n'aurait pas fait mieux on a tendance à
penser en effet un emmanuel macron et
marine le pen dans ce débat et à se dire
que peut-être est-ce que justement l'un
ou l'autre aurait mieux tenu la barre et
donc à partir de là cette ce contraste
fut steam même fossé ce conte strass tu
es bien de nuit aux deux candidats qui
encore une fois c'est leur gros problème
et ça mon avis pour ça que non pas ils
ont raté leurs débats mais que le débat
et pour une occasion manquée et bien les
deux candidats se sont neutralisés
depuis plusieurs semaines benjamin morel
il ya une petite musique qui est monté
sur sur valérie pécresse
certains lui ont reproché son supposé
manque de qualités oratoires en
particulier depuis le big thing mi
février au zénith de paris ce soir et
bien elle a joué la carte de la
publicité est ce que cela peut jouer en
sa faveur alors ça peut jouer en sa
faveur ou et non c'est à dire qu'on
avait quand même vu lors des débats de
la primaire de la droite que on avait
une valérie pécresse n'était pas
mauvaise en débat et qui pouvaient
donner le change alors de manière moins
agressive avec moins d'interruptions
parce que la primaire de la droite
c'était quelque chose qui se passe est
tout de même plus en famille entre
guillemets là on a une valérie pécresse
qui était bien meilleur qu'au zénith
mais qui a probablement été bien moins
bonne que durant ces fameux meeting de
la primature en ces fameux débat de la
primaire de la droite justement parce
que il y avait cette volonté d'aller
chercher la faute chez eric zemmour par
ailleurs on parlait tout à l'heure de la
violence des débats mais on a eu quand
même des deux côtés des attaques qui
étaient des attaques parfois à nos mines
m en tout cas au delà de la cohérence
qui peut s'entendre mais sur des
personnes entourant les candidats sur
des passes sur le passé des candidats et
c'est tout ça qui au bout du compte par
les lecteurs parce que les lecteurs ne
connais pas tous les noms qui ont été
cités 1 ceux qui sont pointés je pars
aux cités les noms mais comme nazi du
côté d'eric zemmour comme presque
islamiste du côté de valérie pécresse
donc au bout du compte vous rentrez dans
une stratégie de la décrédibilisation de
votre adversaire évidemment ça vous
permet de l'envoyer plus bas mais ça
vous abbès wii ou également c'est à dire
que lorsque vous êtes dans une position
de présidentiable eh bien vous tenté de
démonter les arguments sur le fond et
non d'attaquer la crédibilité du
candidat que vous avez en face de vous
vous le laisser se décrédibiliser si
jamais il n'est pas crédible ça l'un
comme l'autre ne sont pas arrivés du
coup les arguments ont baissé ce qui
n'aide pas du poids relevé et le débat
et les candidats alors dans le chat ça
réagit ça réagit beaucoup nous avons
merlin le chambreur qui nous dit que
retenir de ce débat que pécresse dit en
effet tout et son contraire et que
zemmour est resté bloqué en 1960 dudule
14 à nouveau qui nous dit allez 10% pour
les deux ça sera suffisant ou encore
j'ai d'abord qu'ils ne disent à
ressembler à une grosse foire d'empoigné
les commentaires donc plutôt plus tôt et
bien
qu'ils sont qui sont plutôt durs on va
dire avec les avec les candidats ce soir
valérie pécresse et eric zemmour ont
cherché à montrer leur différence et
vous le disiez 1 pour chercher à se
différencier à chercher à imprimer dans
l'opinion il ya un sujet sur lequel ils
sont pas ils sont pas d'accord du tout
c'est sur l'accueil des réfugiés
ukrainien c'était dans la première
partie du débat on va écouter une
séquence et puis on en discute juste
après moi je suis fidèle à la tradition
chrétienne et humaniste de la france en
ce qui concerne l'asile quand un peuple
est subit la guerre sur son sol quand il
est persécuté il doit avoir une
autorisation temporaire de séjour dans
notre pays j'ai dit que les réfugiés
l'ukrainien voulait aller en pologne et
je leur ai placé faut il y en a dont il
y en a les traits de venir en france
laissez-moi vous voyez on m'interrompez
tout le temps donc là l'essentiel ils
veulent aller en pologne tout simplement
parce que ce sont des femmes et des
enfants qui sont près de leur mari et de
leur père ou de leur fils qui se bat
donc ils ne veulent pas aller loin et
c'est pour ça que j'ai proposé d'aider
les polonais et madame pécresse c'est
pour ça que j'ai proposé que l'europe
supprime les scandaleuses
amendes qu'ils ont infligé à la pologne
les réfugiés ukrainien qui souhaitent
venir en france il y en a très peu on
leur donne des visas
au cas par cas pas moi je suis fidèle
alors
benjamin morel il y a plusieurs choses
sur 7 sur cette séquence déjà sur la fin
de la séquence eric zemmour qui dit
certains réfugiés ukrainien qui veulent
absolument venir en france on leur donne
des visas au cas par cas est-ce qu'il a
changé d'avis déjà par rapport à ce
qu'il avait dit il y a une semaine et
puis on a vu alors on a on ne voit pas
dans cette danse sur ces images mais
valérie pécresse lui reproche parce que
eric zemmour dit immigration zéro elle
lui dit elle fait alors finalement vous
n'êtes plus pour les migrations 0 qu'est
ce qu'il faut en penser s'ils voulaient
il ya une évolution et le jeu des deux a
été de montrer ces évolutions il ya une
autre il ya notre extrait où eric
zemmour lui dit oui mais en syrie
lorsqu'il ya eu la guerre en syrie vous
n'étiez pas pour un million d'immigrés
qui arriverait tout d'un coup de
réfugiés qui arrivera en france or là
les ukrainiens bref vous n'êtes pas
cohérente les deux ont cherché en
réalité à démontrer ce que je disais
tout à l'heure d'un côté la cohérence et
de l'incohérence plus tôt et de l'autre
lit réalise le côté irréaliste des
propositions et c'est peut-être ça le
drame de ce débat c'est peut-être que
les deux sont parvenus à leur but d'un
côté quand valérie pécresse dit dans
votre extrait oui mais on fait quand
vous parlez de la pologne vous dites on
fait sauter les amants de la pologne
mais ça concerne l'état doit elle a
raison dire que là dessus on voit mal le
lien qu'eric zemmour fait entre d'un
côté le sujet relatif à l'état de droit
en pologne et les les
ce que ce que sanctionne aujourd'hui la
cge et de l'autre côté l'accueil des
réfugiés ukrainien mais quand elle
faisait moore midi certes oui mais en
syrie vous n'étiez pas pour accueillir
un million de réfugiés il a aussi en
partie raison il montre une forme
d'incohérence de la candidate donc là
les deux hommes plutôt bien préparé leur
débat là dessus ils ont bien réussi à
démonter là quand le candidat qu'ils
avaient en face d'eux démonter sa
logique des montées dans sa cohérence
l'autre sa crédibilité mais du coup ils
n'ont pas forcément bien joué en défense
et on voit que des deux côtés et bien
sûr ce point là c'est plutôt perdant
perdant alors le chat on adule qui nous
dit il faut croire il faut dire qu'avec
deux candidats comme eux macron n'a rien
à craindre un autre internaute qui nous
dit valérie pécresse solide claire et
déterminée ou encore un débat mais moore
macron ça pourrait être intéressant
alors on verra peut-être avoir du lot
sur mais voilà je pense que c'est le
même
alors vous parliez benjamin morel de la
défense des candidats justement sur
cette histoire des réfugiés ukrainien
j'y reviens est ce que vous pensez qu
eric zemmour a convaincu dans sa réponse
valérie pécresse il leur reproche
d'avoir changé d'avis alors je suis pas
sûr que pour le coup il est convaincu
mais l'important n'est peut-être pas
tout à fait là c'est à dire que vous
avez une évolution dans le suivi de la
situation le vrai problème d'eric
zemmour sur ce sujet là c'est que par
rapport à l'électorat de marine le pen
ou à l'électorat de jean luc mélenchon
qui on a pu reprocher d'avoir eu des
positions qui étaient plus ou moins
clair sur le sujet de l'ukraine et des
rapports avec vladimir poutine on a un
électorat zemmourien qui s'est avérée
assez sensible à ce sujet là et donc
aujourd'hui il doit faire montre de
cohérence donc évidemment vous avez une
évolution de la rhétorique mais cette
évolution de la rhétorique en elle même
elle n'est pas problématique c'est à
dire que dès le moment où vous
reconsidérer votre rhétorique en faisant
votre mea culpa pour faire évoluer la
situation
enfin pour évoluer cette rhétorique au
regard de la situation n'est pas
forcément quelque chose les politiques
en ont toujours peur mais ce n'est pas
forcément quelque chose qui est mal vu
par l'électorat le vrai problème d'eric
zemmour c'est justement toujours cette
question de la cohérence d'un de vos
internautes disent eh oui eric zemmour a
une vision un peu des années 50 alors
j'irai pas jusque là mais vous avez chez
eric zemmour cette volonté de montrer
que il a une ligne de cohérence depuis
plusieurs décennies et ils ne bougent
plus rien pourquoi pas ça peut être une
ligne pour arriver à se positionner à
campagne campagne mais du coup lorsque
vous évoluez sur un sujet fût ce celui
ci est bien tout d'un coup vous mettez
en porte à faux sur le sujet de la
cohérence et donc vous nuisez vous même
à votre discours c'est pour ça que ce
qui peut être audible chez certains
candidats les probablement beaucoup plus
chez lui parce que ça rentre ça rentre
en opposition avec ce que justement il
tente d'incarner dans cette campagne est
justement sur ce que vous dites jamais
merelle un internaute nous dit eric
zemmour à propos d'eric zemmour je
suppose toujours aussi nerveux on croit
qu'il va finir par se mordre les pattes
est ce qu'il a été trop nerveux ce soir
eric zemmour alors peut-être moins que
je pense certains de ses proches aurait
pu le craindre c'est à dire que on avait
peur d'un eric zemmour qui occupe tout
d'un coup toute la place et puis qu'il
n'est ce pas parler valérie pécresse qui
apparaît beaucoup plus agressif que
valérie pécresse et avec leurs proches
de misogynie etc qui peut être attaché
aux candidats valérie pécresse a tenté
un moment de jouer sur ce jeu là elle a
attaqué mais sa tournée assez court
parce qu'en réalité il est réussi il a
réussi malgré tout à être relativement
posée à interrompre mes interrompre
toujours sur des sujets de fond sans
être dans une forme d'agressivité
gratuite ou qui auraient pu conférer au
mépris donc on a là dessus plutôt je
dirais un plein de communication qui
n'était pas simple pour lui qui pour moi
est un peu plus tôt un contrat réussi
alors si on parle de valérie pécresse
maintenant il y a eu un autre débat
pendant cette campagne sur valérie
pécresse sur sur l'histoire du grand
remplacement il a été interrogé
là-dessus valérie pécresse avait utilisé
cette expression lors de son meeting au
zénith de paris mi février
les journalistes ruth elkrief faire
interrogé valérie pécresse sur ce sujet
en lui disant est ce que c'est quelque
chose est ce que c'est une expression
qui vous met mal à l'aise oui ou non
valérie pécresse a répondu c'est une
théorie du complot qui jouent sur les
peurs et attise les haines donc elle
répond clairement sans ambiguïté est-ce
que valérie alors eric zemmour lui a
répondu pourtant vous avez utilisé cette
expression est ce que valérie pécresse
sait ce que c'est que ce coup ci est ce
que l a changé d'avis qu'elle a cherché
à mettre de l'eau dans son vin alors
c'est compliqué parce qu'en réalité on a
une valérie pécresse qui est là dessus
et est très clair il ya quelques mois
était beaucoup plus ambiguë lors de ce
fameux meeting au zénith mais dans
quelle mesure s je dirais une une plus
mal tourné d'un rédacteur de discours
dans un discours qui on peut parler de
la forme évidemment mais sur le fond
n'était pas non plus très très bon et
dans quelle mesure pour le coup c'est un
retour à ce que pensent réellement
valérie pécresse c'est difficile à dire
et c'est là dessus que jouèrent examen
encore une fois montré qu'il ya une
incohérence de la candidate parce que si
jamais une candidate est incohérente du
coup vous ne lui fait pas confiance
parce que ça veut dire que vous allez
voter pour elle sans savoir ce qu'elle
fera demain et tout l'art tout
l'argumentaire d'eric zemmour là dessus
et construit là dessus en réalité le
contre argumentaire de valérie pécresse
c'est de dire elle a dit souvent vous
serez impuissant en tant que président
la république parce qu'en réalité sur ce
sujet là bas vous n'aurez pas les
leviers parce que vous n'êtes pas
compétents et c'est cet affrontement des
récits ex tu as été extrêmement fort
notamment sur les mesures relatives à
l'immigration est relative à cette
question 2 des flux migratoires alors
après sur le sujet qu'en remplacement
c'est un sujet assez radioactifs si vous
voulez pour la candidate de droite
pourquoi parce que quand vous prenez les
enquêtes vous avez quand même une
majeure partie de l'électorat de droite
qui n'est pas défiants vis-à-vis de
cette idée est donc à partir de la
rentrée dans un clivage trop fort sur
cette thématique là ça peut vous mettre
en porte à faux avec une partie de
l'électorat de droite en même temps la
prouver et bien c'est
neutraliser tout ce qui pourrait
différencier la droite et d'air d'eric
zemmour d'un côté et même pas de marine
le pen de l'autre parce que marine le
pen n'assume pas directement aujourd'hui
ce vocable donc en réalité c'est vous
déportés à la droite de marine le pen
donc c'est pas assuma pour valérie
pécresse du coup c'est une sorte de
pelote d'épingler stratégiques dont elle
a tranché aujourd'hui le sort mais
peut-être pas forcément à son avantage
il faudra voir comment c'est reçu dans
son électorat qu'elles sont quelle est
justement l'électorat de valérie
pécresse en tout cas qu'elle ait
l'électorat qu'elle a cherché à toucher
ce soir alors il ya plusieurs électorale
je pense c'est à dire que d'un côté il
ya en effet une petite porosité avec
l'électorat zemmour est donc là il faut
montrer une porosité avec l'électorat
est mort mais également un électorat de
droite et l'eire qui a biberonné à eric
zemmour pour une partie d'entre eux lui
notamment l'électorat plus jeune qui a
lu ses livres et c'est donc à partir de
là il faut quand même être capable avec
un logiciel un peu scientiste entre
guillemets de parler à cet électorat là
mais encore une fois le gros de porosité
entre pécresse et les autres candidats
c'est avec emmanuel macron et donc il
faut montrer quel est le meilleur
barrage contre justement eric zemmour
dont tu as peur une partie de
l'électorat de centre-droit qui juge que
justement ce n'est pas ça qu'il faut
c'est pas sa vision de la politique et
que à choisir entre valérie pécresse
emmanuel macron peut-être choisir est il
plutôt valérie pécresse mais le fait est
que ce n'est pas la meilleure justement
pour contrer une forme d'union des
droites autour d'eric zemmour beaucoup
plus radicale et que le meilleur
candidat face à ça c'est plutôt et
emmanuel macron donc vote utile en
faveur d' emmanuel macron donc en
affrontant directement eric zemmour
restait l'un des objectifs du soir
s'était également montré que elle
pouvait être crédible face à ces
stratégies la droite face à eric zemmour
est-ce qu'elle y est parvenu là c'est
toutes les limites que l'on assigné
merlin le chambreur nous dise ce soir
c'était davantage un débat sur l'avenir
de la droite que sur l'avenir de la
france justement sur 7 sur cette
question de l'électorat de droite il ya
un sondage ifop benjamin morel qui est
sorti donc hier soir il dit que 49% des
électeurs de françois fillon se
reporteraient au premier tour sur un
vote pour valérie pécresse ils sont 27%
à se reporter sur emmanuel macron il 18%
pour eric zemmour
l'enjeu de cet électorat de la droite
dite traditionnelle la droite de
françois fillon
lequel des deux candidats a selon vous
le plus convaincu cet électorat là ce
soir
le problème ce serait de considérer
cette lg pas répondre à votre question
je suis désolé ce serait de considérer
cet électorat comme un bloc et c'est un
peu ça probablement l'une des erreurs de
la perspective un peu union des droits
c'est à dire que c'est un électorat qui
fondamentalement clivé dans ses intérêts
mais également dans une partie de ses
valeurs alors il peut se retrouver sur
certains sujets le sujet migratoires par
exemple est encore un élément de clivage
droite gauche assez prégnant mais les
électeurs ne votent pas que sur cet
enjeu là et donc à partir de là vous
avez des électorats qui sont des
électorats fondamentalement divers assez
fluide en réalité dont la porosité avec
le centre est beaucoup plus importante
la communion de valeurs entre une partie
de cet électorat et emmanuel macron est
beaucoup plus forte qu avec eric zemmour
de même contre la droite on va dire plus
conservatrice et eric zemmour il ya plus
de points communs que entre elles et
emmanuel macron donc on a plutôt une
forme de partage aujourd'hui que c'était
de select électorat fillon est malgré
tout un ventre mou et se montre moins on
le retrouve aujourd'hui chez valérie
pécresse c'est à dire que c'est un
électorat qui est un électorat qui ne
veut pas passer chez emmanuel macron et
qui ont parce que pour des questions de
valeurs et ses g et qui en même temps a
encore peur de ce que représente eric
zemmour et pour valérie pécresse tout
l'enjeu étant fait d'élargir cette base
électorale de reconquérir l'électorat
fillon en essayant de tenir les deux
bouts de l'autre côté pourrait aisément
il faut arriver à mordre cet électorat
qui est plus conservateur chez valérie
pécresse en paille 40% de porosité que
manuellement on sait qu'elle est encore
60% qui n'est pas prêt à aller voter
emmanuel macron il faut aller chercher
cet électorat donc aujourd'hui le
principe pour valérie pécresse était
vraiment d'élargir cette base en étant
plus convaincant qu'eric zemmour sur une
base qu'elles maîtrisent déjà en grande
partie pour eric zemmour eh bien c'était
de mordre non pas sur l'ensemble de cet
électorat mais sur une petite partie est
ce que les deux ils ont réussi à mon
sens pour l'instant on est quand même
plutôt encore une fois dans un match nul
est ce qu'il y à un moment où deux qui
vous a particulièrement marqué dans ce
débat
je crois que vous avez plusieurs moments
où vous avez les deux candidats qui
tentent justement de de démontrer que
vous avez une position c'est-à-dire que
lorsque au moment du débat sur
l'immigration
vous avez un eric zemmour qui dit qu' il
ya une forme de mollesse dans la
politique de valérie pécresse et qu'au
bout du compte qu'il tente de démontrer
avec des chiffres que si jamais l
arrivée au pouvoir ce qu'elle fait ne
changera rien et bien là vous avez un
moment qui est assez important et de
même que lorsque eric zemmour de l'autre
lorsque valérie pécresse de l'autre côté
tente de démonter le programme d'eric
zemmour en expliquant que en fait ce
n'est pas faisable tout bêtement parce
que eh bien on pourrait pas faire
descendre les clandestins des avions si
on n'a pas d'accord avec ces pays vous
avez également une attaque de la
crédibilité
là dessus le débat migratoire plus que
l'ukraine qui me semble être un débat
important sur le fond mais qui n'est pas
forcément un débat qui marque autre
chose que des postures entre les deux
candidats le débat sur l'immigration est
vraiment quelque chose qui marque un
vrai clivage en termes d'un côté de
crédibilité et de l'autre de cohérence
et ça pour le coup l'un comme l'autre
ont bien su l'exploiter il ya deux
autres moments on les a évoqué un petit
peu tout à l'heure ce sont les moments
où ce sont des attaques ad hominem qui
ont été lancés le premier de eric
zemmour entre patrick karam et cetera
l'autre côté de l'autre côté avec avec
valérie pécresse qui attaquent
l'entourage d'eric zemmour soit aisément
qu'il avait dès qu'il ya un salut nazi
cette fois les sorties les mythiques
d'eric zemmour exactement et là vous
avez une sorte de réduction à
l'adversaire à ceux qui pourraient le
décrédibiliser le plus parce que
évidemment quand vous avez en face de
vous une candidat de droite et que vous
êtes même vous même un candidat de
droite et que vous dites que ce candidat
de droite est proche des islamistes
c'est une façon de mort politique que
vous vous infligez d'ailleurs valérie
pécresse lui rend la pareille en suit
ensuite citant tariq ramadan je suis pas
sûr encore une fois que l'un et l'autre
ait pu gagner à cette séquence et je la
trouve assez emblématique des débats en
réalité c'est à dire que à trop vouloir
attaquer l'adversaire à trop vouloir
attaquer non pas sur le fond non pas sur
son programme mais vraiment sur sa
crédibilité sur ce qui fait de lui un
présidentiable et lyon ne se grandit pas
et on affaiblit et l'adversaire est soi
même et seule touche pas l'électorat
recherché ça peut toucher l'électorat
mais en réalité vous toucher un
électorat qui est déjà convaincu c'est à
dire que c'est toute la difficulté sur
ce type de débat vous avez deux types
d'électorat vous avez vous supporters et
vos supporters ils viennent au meeting
et réagissent quand vous citez tariq
ramadan quand vous citez et c'est là
tout d'un coup tout le monde sait qui
c'est et là vous avez une
cristallisation pour un électorat qui
est un peu plus loin de tout ça
l'électorat moins politisés et qui ait
l'électorat en jeu en réalité ce que
l'électorat le plus politisé il sait
déjà pour qui il va voter lectorat moins
politisés n'a peut-être pas tout à fait
entendu parler de la sphère des sms de
entre eric zemmour et tariq ramadan il
peut apprendre quelque chose mais je ne
suis pas sûr qu'il le cesi serait mon
bien et là pour le coup c'est peut-être
un électorat que vous perdez et un
électorat avec lequel vous vous perdez
en attaquant sur des points qui ne sont
peut-être pas à la hauteur d'une
présidentielle ça veut pas dire que ça
doit pas être évoqués dans le cas d'une
présidentielle pouvait envoyer des dieux
tenant attaqué le candidat sur 110 ont
regardé ce candidat n'a pas traîné par
ce que parce que mais quand vous même
être un présidentiable il faut éviter de
sortir ce genre de choses justement sur
ce que vous dites benjamin morel un
internaute réagi sur le chat et nous dit
dommage que dans un tel débat au lieu de
discuter et de proposer des solutions un
casse l'adversaire il ya un débat sur le
sur le tchat on a un internaute par
exemple qui nous dit valérie pécresse a
montré l'image d'une femme d'état
crédible solide est prête à diriger la
france et puis
qui lui répond pécresse est mauvaise
elle sonne faux en plus elle dit une
chose sans détailler la mesure répond un
autre
benjamin morel est ce que l'enjeu pour
pour valérie pécresse eric zemmour ce
soir ce n'était pas aussi de montrer la
différence de leurs programmes et de
créer une forme de clivage entre eux
finalement pour que parce que là il ya
un clivage qui est en train de
s'installer petit à petit de se
réinstaller finalement c'est le clivage
emmanuel macron
marine le pen est ce que finalement
voilà eric zemmour et valérie pécresse
ne pas chercher à créer un nouveau
clivage alors ils ont cherché à créer un
clivage est un clivage essai de leurs
difficultés sur les personnalités parce
que sur les programmes non pas qu'ils
aient pas des vraies différences mais il
ya une volonté au contraire de montrer
une forme de rapprochement souvenez vous
eric zemmour à lille qui réutilise la
phrase de nicolas sarkozy gagne plus
pour gagner plus il ya une volonté
aujourd'hui pour eczéma de montrer qu'en
réalité il a une forme de successeur en
un peu plus dur et surtout en un peu
plus crédit valérie pécresse a aussi
ressorti l'expression du karcher bien
sûr de nicolas sarkozy et de d'autres en
effet valérie pécresse eh bien je
cherche à se montrer plus sarkozy ce que
nicolas sarkozy en ressortant
l'expression du karcher et en droitisant
entre guillemets son programme sur les
sujets migratoire est le sarkozy zèle
ciotti de valérie pécresse et d'eric
zemmour cherche à récupérer l'héritage
de nicolas sarkozy alors pas que de
nicolas sarkozy c'est à dire que ils se
rendent bien compte que d'un côté vous
avez marine le pen qui compte je dirais
une la frange de la droite nationale
populiste populaire donc avec pour le
coup un électorat populaire qui va voter
marine le pen question pour ce marine le
pen c est ce qu il s'abstiendra ou est
ce qui viendra voter ça c'est son
problème à elle pour le coup et de
l'autre côté un électorat macro nhien
qui est un électorat de centre droite
mais qui est un électorat on va dire qui
est plus aisé et qui est plus libérale
donc il reste ensuite un ventre mou
entre les deux un électorat qui est plus
conservateur un électorat qui est moins
libérale qui est moins populaire et qui
se retrouvent dans les valeurs
traditionnelles de la droite et qui a
voté sarkozy très majoritairement cet
électorat il est sensible à la fois aux
mythes sarkozy le candidat qui l'a
emporté le dernier candidat de droite
qui l'emporté ce qui signifie quelque
chose c'est à dire que tout d'un coup ça
peut créer une forme de nostalgie et
d'adhésion et puis également de
dépendance aux sentiers et de l'autre
côté il est sensible à un certain nombre
de signaux un discours à la fois
conservateur mais en même temps libéral
au niveau économique forte sur les
questions d'identité mais en même temps
mais en même temps pas tout à fait
fermée en matière de droits de l'homme
etc et c'est ce même espace politique
aujourd'hui que valérie pécresse et eric
zemmour tente d'aller chercher alors
c'est un électorat qui paradoxalement
apparaître écrivait même s'il partage
beaucoup de choses en terme de valeur
mais ça oblige les deux à rapprocher
leurs programmes et ça oblige les deux à
rapprocher également la rhétorique
qu'ils emploient du coup faire la
différence sur les programmes et sur les
mesures
évidemment du coup assez compliqué donc
vous faites une différence sur la
crédibilité vous faites une différence
sur la constance pour expliquer que
certes je propose à peu près la même
chose mais que moi je le ferai parce que
j'ai la constance ou que moi je propose
peut-être un peu la même chose mais je
suis crédible et donc je sais ce que je
proposais les mesures que je propose
permettront réellement d'atteindre
l'objectif c'est plutôt ses rhétorique
lakic on a vu s'affronter beaucoup plus
qu'une opposition de programmes qui pour
le coup a été soit un peu ésotérique
soit un peu stérile assez rapide assez
rarement constructive sur nicolas
sarkozy vous en parliez on a flight 80,2
qui nous dit sarkozy reste la référence
il influence encore tout le monde
politique beaucoup de mesures actuelles
viennent de lui et pas de françois
fillon et puis on a une question pour
vous benjamin morel c'est merlin
chambreur qui kivu la pause il nous dit
la meilleure façon de se
présidentialiser n'était elle pas de ne
pas participer à ce genre de sous débat
et j'ajouterais benjamin morel est ce
que finalement vous disiez que valérie
pécresse et eric zemmour ont eu du mal à
développer leur leur programme ce soir
est ce que finalement ce genre de débat
permet de s que c'est le bon moment est
ce que c'est le bon lieu pour développer
son programme alors le problème c'est
quand est ce que vous le développer
autrement le problème d'un meeting c'est
que vous parlez essentiellement à des
convaincus les convaincus sont dans la
salle alors ensuite vous avez une
possibilité de à celle meeting ça passe
dans certains réseaux sociaux ça passe
un peu au journal de 20 heures les
chaînes d'information en continu leur
transmettent mais vous touchez un
parfaitement un large public l'avantagé
d'un débat c'est que vous toucher
d'autres publics ou toucher le public
potentiellement de votre adversaire et
donc ça peut permettre de créer une
forme de porosité et par ailleurs et
bien vous allez chercher un public de
curieux donc ça peut être intéressant
d'un point de vue électoral est en effet
c'est pas une bonne façon de se
présidentialiser n'importe quel duel
hors second tour à la rigueur n'est pas
une bonne façon de se présidentialiser
sauf à ce qui est vraiment un écart de
niveau entre les deux candidats mais
malgré tout c'est nécessaire c'est
nécessaire surtout quand vous êtes dans
une position difficile dans une campagne
justement quand vous avez besoin d'aller
chercher des électeurs quand vous pouvez
vous permettre
suivez mon regard vers emmanuel macron
parce que les sondages vous flatte parce
que également vous êtes présent la
république de dire moi je ne débat pas
est de toute façon je marquerai quand
même la campagne et bien
tant mieux pour vous c'est à dire qu'à
ce moment là il faut pas y aller quand
vous êtes marine le pen que vous êtes
dans une situation qui vous permet
d'éviter pour l'instant de vous mouiller
dans ce genre d'affaires vous pouvez
vous permettre de dire j'attends de voir
avant d'y aller en revanche quand vous
êtes deux candidats qui sont dans les
mêmes eaux pour être 3e et qui
souhaitent devenir au moins second dans
dans cette campagne ben vous n'avez pas
réellement choix vous êtes
nécessairement amené à ce type de format
qui est pour tout candidat extrêmement
risquée qui est un passage un passage
obligé en tout cas c'est ce que vous
voulez c'est un passage qui en effet est
un passage pour eux assez difficilement
évitable benjamin morel eric zemmour et
valérie pécresse aujourd'hui dans les
sondages c'est peu ou prou 12% pour
l'instant il se hisse eux se battent
chacun pour la troisième place est ce
que ce débat peut leur permettre de
relancer leur campagne alors on a dit
toutes les limites de ce débat pour eux
donc à partir de là j'aurais plutôt
tendance à vous dire non mais c'est
malgré tout possible c'est à dire que si
jamais on a dans une partie de
l'électorat sur certains sujets on
considère que bien il y en a un qui
était plus crédible que l'autre eh bien
ça peut permettre de gagner un ou deux
points et cinq coups de poing au vu de
la situation sondagière ils peuvent être
extrêmement intéressante parce que
actuellement qu'est ce qui fragilise et
valérie pécresse eric zemmour c'est d'un
côté une forme de
mise à plat de la campagne par des
sujets qui ne sont pas les leurs
notamment le sujet ukrainien et de
l'autre côté un effet vote utile qui
commence à se déclencher vis-à-vis
d'autres candidats quand vous prenez les
enquêtes de ce long tour quand vous
prenez les enquêtes de premier tour on
voit qu'on a évidemment emmanuel macron
qui est mieux placé que valérie pécresse
et qu'on a une marine le pen qui est
mieux placé à ce stade-là qu'eric
zemmour donc si jamais vous gagnez un
petit peu de visibilité que vous allez
chercher d'autres électeurs on n'a pas
parlé mais on a affaire à un débat qui a
commencé sur tf1 donc vous touchez autre
chose que le public habitué à la
politique qui biberonne aux chaînes
d'information en continu et donc les
lecteurs un des six est pas pour qui
voter qui a une vision politique je
dirais à ces fous du débat politique
actuel aussi parce que la compagne est
quand même très sains visibiliser et
bien il peut avoir malgré tout si ce
n'est à avoir été convaincus au moins
avoir découvert des candidats on a des
candidats qui ont un taux de notoriété
assez faible eric zemmour valérie
pécresse sont connus de plus en plus par
le grand public mais n'était pas encore
beaucoup il ya six mois pour beaucoup
donc ça permet malgré tout d'être
visible d'aller chercher quelques
électeurs et ça peut permettre de gagner
éventuellement quelques points et de
déclencher quelque chose ce ne sera pas
déclencher que par ce débat mais ça peut
permettre de gagner quelques points qui
ensuite vous rendre plus médiatique vous
rendre plus visible et ensuite c'est un
cercle vertueux il ya loin de la coupe
aux lèvres alors ce débrief touche à sa
fin on va pas tarder à à conclure
benjamin morel on à une question d'un
internaute qui nous dit quelle audience
a eu ce débat sur tf1 puis sur lci alors
on peux pas vous dire encore parce que
les chiffres de médiamétrie ne sont pas
encore sortis on le sera demain matin et
justement cela m'offre une parfaite
transition vers ma prochaine question
benjamin morel même si on l'a dit ce
débat a montré ses limites notamment sur
la forme avec deux candidats très
agressif ce soir en tout cas
sur tf1 en prime time eric zemmour
valérie pécresse c'est au moins
l'assurance de faire les gros titres
demain est-ce que ça c'est pas quand
même déjà une victoire pour les deux
candidats ça c'est déjà une victoire
c'est ce qu'on évoquait tout à l'heure
tu as des vous toucher d'autres
électeurs et vous marquez la campagne le
problème de cette campagne c'est
qu'aujourd'hui elle a du mal à vivre
parce que vous avez d'autres actualités
qui se télescopent et qui du coup
tendent à l'étouffée et a étouffé à la
fois les sujets et des candidats le fait
d'avoir ce type de moment médiatique
permet malgré tout d'être visible il ya
une loi en sciences politiques qui est
un peu triste mais qui
existe plus vous êtes visible plus les
gens vous connaissent en réalité plus
ils sont amenés à voter pour vous vous
ne votez pas pour un candidat que vous
ne connaissez pas voter pour un candidat
que vous connaissez et mieux vaut être
un candidat coût qui est connu mais dont
vous doutez plutôt qu'un candidat
totalement inconnu est donc là on a une
mise en visibilité des deux candidatures
et ça pour le coup au vu de l'état de
cette campagne c'est quand même une
belle chose de gagner merci beaucoup
benjamin morel on se débrouille fait
merci à vous chers internautes de nous
avoir suivis nous sommes disponible en
replay sur lefigaro.fr et sur la chaîne
youtube figaro live merci beaucoup pour
vos commentaires pour vous question
n'oubliez pas demain matin la matinale
radio classique diffusée sur lefigaro.fr
et puis le buzz tva midi d'amiens
canivet et nathalie schuck reçoivent
sonia mabrouk et dimitri pavlenko et
puis bien entendu point de vue à 18h
vous retrouverez vincent roux et tous
ses invités bonne soirée à tous et bonne
nuit